من الرياض تنضم الينا بطله النسخه الاولى
من سعود عادل المطربه همس فكري صباح الخير
همس
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير يا مس مبروك اللقب صباح النور
يعني السؤال الاول بدنا نسالك صفحتي
اليوم على ان تكون في المقدمه فنيا
بعد هذا الفوز شفنا هلا حدا فات ركب لك
المايك ودخلنا بكواليس الفن والمسارح
وتظبيط الاضاءه
الحين اسمع الصوت
كيف تعمل تعملين اليوم بعد هذا الفوز بان
تكوني في المقدمه وان تكوني من دم من ضمن
الفنانين كتير منهم من الفنانين البرامج
اخرى سباق على على ان يكونوا مطربين
اصبحوا نجوم كيف تتعاملي مع هذا الامر انت
اليوم الفائزه بالسعودي ايضا
اول شيء امسي عليكم
افضل اللقب بالعربي عن عن سعودي ايدل
محبوبه السعوديه كذا ثقيل يعني والى وزنه
كيف تغيرت حياتك قبل اللقب وبعد اللقب
طبعا تغيرت كثير محبه الناس في كل مكان
ينادوني احنا فخورين فيك يعني هذا احس زاد
المسؤوليه علي انه اول امراه سعوديه تنال
لقب في سعودي ايدل ان هي تكون سعودي ايدل
يعني هذا فخر وعز لنا في بلاد السعوديه
الحمد لله
واحنا اكيد رح تسمعينا شيء حلو تفضلي
عيوني تامر
يا غايبه
[موسيقى]
الا على
الخافق سلام
ردي علي
يا همسه العاشق سلام سلام
ردي وخذي مني
العمر
اقطف لكن نجمه
وادوب ليك
واذوب لي الجور
والبسك ثوب الن
سيم
وعطر ايامك ايام
وعطر عطرك
[موسيقى]
سؤال سمر بدي اسالك
المغنيين السعوديين
[موسيقى]
والله كل الفنانين صراحه او اكثر واحد
يعني اسماعيل او معجبه سعودي
في عبد المجيد
رابع يعني كلهم فنانين كبار يعني نعم
دائما يخطر على بالي البارحه شفت اللقطه
لما قالوا اسمك فانت مثل يعني ما مصدق او
مثل حلم اريد اعرف شو اللي مره في بالك
بهذه اللحظات عديده
مرت كل سنين حياتي في هذاك المكان يعني
حسيت انه هل ممكن حلمي تحقق يعني في بلاد
السعوديه
الله دائما تتحقق الاخلاق اكيد ان شاء
الله همس مقطع ثاني لاي فنان سعود تفضلي
اوك حاضر اول شيء لعيد الام ممكن بما انه
اليوم عيد الام اذا حابه تغني لنا شي لعيد
الام براحتك انت بتختاري يلا
ست
الحبايب يا حبيب
يا اغلى من روحي ودمي
يا حنينه وكلك طيبه
يا ربي يخليك يا امي
يا ربي
يخليك يا امي
يا ست
الحبايب ايه يا حبيبه يا حبيبه
طب هذا السؤال قبل الاخير شو هلق الخطوه
الجايه شو بصير هل تقومين
بعقود هلا اكيد في عنا
30 امريكي اكيد رح يكون عندك عقد معهم وهل
تختاري هلا
البوم جديد لالحان لكلمات
اي طبعا بلاتي مهتمه فينا جدا طبعا هي
الام والداعمه اللي انا بعد السعودي ايدل
واحنا قاعدين نتشاور على كذا اغاني وان
شاء الله خير يعني
شيء حلو ان شاء الله همس محبوبه السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا لتواجدك معنا اليوم وان شاء
الله طيب ورحله سعيده يا رب مبروك
بالتوفيق